[Musique]
bonsoir nesher petit ami paul watson
nicolas et pimprenelle ont été très
sages ces jours ci au ca cheuvreux
poteau pour les récompenser nous allons
leur raconter la suite d'une jolie
histoire qu'ils connaissent bien cette
envie de leur montrer ton beau livre
d'image le nours jupons ours ou l'euro
que je suis du coup jouby's le module tu
ne changeras jamais mon cher ne nous
recevrons je suis oblige on le chemin
aux boeufs qu'est ce que tu attends de
tagro ce pack vous avez froid vous
allumez votre bidon c'est un livre aux
cabistes marché c'est la suite d'une
histoire que vous aimez beaucoup alors
qu'est ce que c'est exactement les
enfants là on s'assoit nous possédons
pas comme ça
non seulement à vous patron ce matin-là
le jardin de yang chut chut le petit
chinois et bien agitée tous les oiseaux
piailler ensemble il est pourtant très
tout le soleil vient à peine de se lever
et dix ans le petit âne se met lui aussi
à crier aussi fort qu'il peut au stylo
en sont un
karine est propre mais oui il prend son
bain et il a aperçu ce vilain gros
vilain qui est en train de voler tous
les nids d'hirondelles du jardin et de
la maison
yang chu que les cris de ils en ont
réveillé regarde par la fenêtre voit ce
gros vilain il prend son bâton et papa
pas au nom gros vilain se sauver en
avant et en dix ans que juju il saute
sur le dos du petit âne encore tout
mouillé et se lance à la poursuite du
vilain qui est partie au marché vendre
les jolies nids d'hirondelles qu'est ce
qu'on fait avec les nids d'hirondelles
de la peau sous eau ni du rond bleu
ces pauvres petites hirondelles pas moi
j'en mangerai pas de cette soupe et en
ayant que juju courent si vite qu'ils
arrivent presque en même temps que gros
vilain au marché le retrouve et aux
propres ou sur la tête à gruyère qui
part se cacher tout honteux en pleurant
ce film yanks eu je ne recommencerai
plus je te le promets le petit chinois
et son âne reprennent tous les nids
d'hirondelles et les rapportent chez eux
ils remettent à leur place et écoutent
tous contents
le champ des parents et des bébés
hirondelles qui les remercie de leur
avoir rendu leur nid leur bord
l'histoire une très jolie cette histoire
merci petit marchand de sable allons les
petits os tout haut
bonne nuit le petit nom la jette à la
ligne à deux
bonne nuit non à demain bonne nuit
nicolas vanier coronel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit pape rhône elle bonne
nuit petit nicolas bonne nuit tous les
enfants allaient sagement vous coucher
et faites de beaux rêves
faute de pour mollo potro alors en route
mon cher nounours
bonne nuit à demain à domont bonne nuit
[Musique]
à
e